good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast happy Tuesday
hope everyone's having an amazing day I
am Claude that is Jax hey Jax h1d I'm
doing well turdy thank you for asking
Happy Valentine's Day to my favorite
turd
I'm wearing my heart sweater in honor of
today's festivities yeah I was feeling I
was feeling romantic I'm wearing all
brown today and in honor of my favorite
turd
oh that is so thoughtful I am moved
deeply by your grand gesture and just
know it means the world to me even down
to the brown leggings
I committed
to the turd committed to the turd with
my little slippers that well they're not
slippers they're like go you know
Street shoes and they say Ny just all
turdy things
because you miss your New York 30. I
miss that New York turd
well it is Valentine's Day the day of
love I'm actually committed to several
men this holiday season I've got Harry
this is an order of importance I've got
Harry I've got Theo I've got Ben I've
got I'm sorry Levi too Harry Levi
Theo Ben
Bruno
it's an embarrassment of riches yeah
Mom's boys are her heart and soul this
Valentine's Day and I'll be celebrating
with them but as far as actually
celebrating like
I don't think we're doing diddly squat
like I think Zach and I have to agree
that we're just gonna let this year pass
and like I'm not offended like I do not
need a flower I don't need a card I
don't need a chocolate I don't need a
gift like I just need like and I don't I
don't need a date this year like I just
need like time for myself you know
that's that's fair I'm not gonna lie
like if I don't get flowers like I will
be starting if I like come on like
it's really not that hard but did you
get anything for Ben
no do you get a car actually
no I usually like we've kind of let
Valentine's Day slip a little bit over
the years because our anniversary is so
close and Harry's birthday there's just
a lot going on but I always get a curd
and this year not only did I not get a
card I'm not get I'm not running to the
store today I'm not gonna try in like
the Nago one like
it is what it is
I just feel like in you know
heterosexual relationships like
Valentine's days for the girl like I'm
not gonna give a card I'm just gonna get
one I'm not gonna give flowers but I'd
like to receive them so you're saying I
should just sit back and like expect
that even though I didn't lift a finger
today that I should get something
yeah that's literally what I'm saying
okay well you just like text my husband
and let him know that
um I'm also while I didn't get bet
anything like I curated our plans for
this evening I procured the tickets so
that's what are you doing
me and Ben are going to Sushi and then
Billy Joel well don't tell everyone
where you're going to dinner
Billy Joel
yeah
what's the matter with the clothes I'm
wearing can't you tell that they're out
of style I feel like it's gonna be
packed I feel like of course he does
like a show at the Garden every month
but I think you know it's gonna be full
of lovebirds I know we're actually going
with the tailors so we're doing like a
double date Valentines and I'm excited I
never actually make plans for
Valentine's Day ever because I think
it's like a dumb corporate holiday but
it's cute I think it's so cute and even
though I'm not participating this year
as far as I know like look at Zach he
probably like booked a sitter
fired up fired up the jet literally that
would never happen
um no because you have a child no but
like he could like book a sitter
he good he got
um I don't think those things are
happening and even though we're not like
celebrating this year I'm not
anti-valentine's day I think it's so
cute I think when you're in so many
different stages of your relationship
like it's so great to reaffirm like when
you're dating it can really like
solidify a make a fledgling couple you
know and I think that's so cute and uh
you know when you're engaged when you
just have like time but right now I'm
just I don't have time this year but I
look forward to celebrating next year
and I'm not like boycotting the holiday
or anything and everybody who's
celebrating like I love seeing your
celebrations and your posts it's just we
ran out of time this year
listen you've got a child I can't
understand I feel like I've already
given up in so many aspects of my
relationship and I can only imagine how
much worse it's going to get when I have
a child you know like I stopped shaving
my legs yeah I I don't even want to know
the type of Beast Ben is going to be
married to come you know my child
rearing years yeah like I'm I'm hopeful
that this is just a one-year sort of
thing like maybe next year we'll get
back on track or we'll do something for
our anniversary which is in a few days
and and I feel like you don't need to do
something for both Valentine's Day and
anniversary we like to group it
well last year was probably your best
Valentine's Day Ever right because Harry
was what like five days old one day old
because his birthday was yesterday I
forgot that Valentine's Day happens on
the same day every year you know not
like other holidays yeah last year was
even busier because Harry was born the
day before Valentine's Day so our
Valentine's Day was just full of love
Zach did get me like a huge venusa floor
flower arrangement one thing about Zach
is he is keeping Venus a floor in
business he loves that company yeah so
that was really cute and they were like
all blue because enemy had just had a
boy and they smelled really good so that
was really nice uh and then our
anniversary I don't think we didn't I
mean we had a three day old like we
didn't do anything yeah
when's your anniversary
the 17th of February
not me like always thinking it was an
idea because I got married in 2019. so
it's 2 17 19. I that I get confused too
what's my wedding anniversary
September
seventh no and they close 17th yes we're
both the 17. oh my God look at us I
honestly never put that together so now
it'll be so much easier for me to
remember we're so cute we're so like
harmonious harmonious we're not
acrimonious not so far not today because
today is about love
today's about love today for me is also
about fashion relief
relief I was talking all day yesterday I
was like so excited to be here today
this morning having this thing behind me
last night was my big Fashion Week event
yeah your girl modeled she did comedy it
was actually like seeing the event all
put together it was kind of brilliant I
think like it's really hard to stand out
as a brand during Fashion Week everybody
does the same things and you just have
to be like the biggest and the baddest
and the most celebrities and it's like
it gets kind of monotonous and people
forget and your show is so short
um but Cynthia Riley like her idea to
have the clothes there were no models so
the clothes were modeled by comedians of
all different like ages Heights sizes
and
so there were six comedians I was one of
them and a host Esther so seven and
everyone was dressed in the new line so
we all had our show looks and then right
after our sets we changed into new
outfits and by the time the last
comedian was done we all came out on
stage and like took a bow with Cynthia
in our second looks so she got to like
really show off I think it was a total
of like 14 or 15 looks
um her clothes looked amazing and you
got to see like if you were there like
you had to see clothes on like real
people with real bodies like moving on
stage and like it was really it was a
brilliant concept for Cynthia rally and
I was like so excited to be a part of it
I loved my outfits like I I've been told
like maybe I get to keep them they'll be
Messenger to me I won't hold my breath I
feel like they knew they were like yeah
just take it off so we could like shoot
it and then we'll send it to you I'm
like yeah okay whatever I've never seen
those pants again but I'll buy them
myself because I really love them
um I had two great outfits my set was
good I definitely felt you know really
out of my league especially you know I
spent a few hours before
um in the hotel suite with all the other
female comics and there's so like it was
at a hotel
the like we were all in a hotel suite
prior to the event upstairs above the
Sony Music Hall
um while people were filling in we were
all getting like touch up on Glam
getting Cynthia came in and dressed each
of us and styled us
um
so I spent like a decent amount of time
with all the other girls and I
definitely like I don't really suffer
from imposter syndrome I'm like no [__]
I'm great like I need to be here but I
was feeling like major like a fraud
because these were like like seasoned
Comics who've been you know doing this
for like 15 years and they were all
really nice and I was I'm so glad I did
it but I was definitely like quaking
it's good to challenge yourself
a hundred percent and do you feel so
accomplished today
I do I mean I'm so I feel like half of
like something like that half of my
anxiety and nerves is centered around
how I look like does do the clothes fit
me do I look good do I like my hair and
makeup
um and Cynthia knows how to dress a
woman you know
and she was like her during the fittings
like her major concern was like does
everyone feel good like do you look good
but do you feel good I felt great all
the clothes were like tailored to
Perfection for me
um so once like that was squared away
and I knew what I was wearing and I knew
that it fit and I knew I felt good and
that I could move around on stage I
would say half of my like nerves went
away but then the obvi like the
performance anxiety kicked in but it was
great it was honestly an amazing night
for comedy an amazing night for facial
for women for models and amazing for
women and women
in comedy
that's you
yeah it was great I had a blast
I'm so glad and thank you for taking us
along on the journey
um and behind the scenes of the Fashion
World
fashion is you know your passion your
throat man
fashionism I I have a passion for
fashion
are there any other Passions
the redheads
well thank you for bringing that up
because I don't know if you saw but
yesterday we celebrated I did three year
anniversary of the redheads which was so
crazy we're on our 40th book
wow and we're just loving book club
podcast life so I really feel like you
started it like six months ago I know
that's because we're so fresh
and my perception of time is completely
warped everything happens we know that
everything has happened three to four
months ago or yesterday yeah and Harry
was five days old on Valentine's Day
obviously
um no it's a great time to become a
redhead the next book we're reading is
the measure by Nikki Ehrlich and it
literally says on the cover like this
book is amazing for book clubs read with
Jenna chose it and she always chooses
premium books so I haven't read it yet
but I just know it's gonna be a fire
book club choice and it's gonna spark
interesting dialogue
it's all that matters said the redheads
it's so true so it's never too late to
join us on your oh
you go don't feel intimidated I feel
like if you're not a redhead you might
be like Jackie has this thing there's 40
books how could I catch up you could
start at any time to become a redhead
you could buy the book today the measure
by Nikki Ehrlich and you tune into our
next episode which drops the first
Thursday of March and you'll be caught
up that's how it goes Jump Right In or
or you could just like read a book from
the last 40 and go listen to the episode
read a book any book yes you can yeah
give me a word
any word and I'll show you it is Greek
redheads
redhead comes from the Greek word
which means
burnt
[Laughter]
thank you for that
I literally love that movie more than
more than I've ever loved anything I
know
did you know that Tom Hanks and Rita
Wilson like produced that movie no I
didn't that goes in the plus column for
them
yeah I found that out on the good guys
podcast when I was a guest the good guys
I was a guest on the good guys and my
episode good girl because I'm a good
girl I am a good girl
cause you're a good girl and you know it
honestly that video of Pia Mia
singing that song oh goodness
and Kanye at the Kardashian family
dinner table I believe it was posted on
Kik Kik remember that platform
that
really was one of
the weirdest things on the planet you
know
yeah but I think it also goes to show
that you could have all the connections
in the world you could literally yes
Drake's song for him at an intimate
dinner party and it doesn't guarantee
success
no that's actually so true I have often
thought about what happened to the
relationship between Pia Mia and the
Kardashians because she was like a tried
and true Kylie girl they were like
propping her up with her singing she did
go on to have and she still does she's
pretty big on Tick Tock and she has like
a singing career but it's not even
remotely close to what it should be
given like her comeuppance and given
that kick video yeah so that's just a
good lesson so it's so true
no there's no lesson because it doesn't
make sense someone who was like really
genuinely talented so well connected
beautiful like really had all the
makings of a star I feel like maybe she
took a step back
hmm which I always respect because the
industry is just
toxic and she's she probably saw some
things
Maybe
like Addison
I also think she took a really big
earner on only fans
oh well that's good to Be Your Own Boss
let me double check that I'm like pretty
sure she's like one of the top or I'm
actually making that up I've like
literally never looked at her Instagram
let's see what's going on
yeah no she's on here
and she's like one of the top earners
it's 15. so many followers oh she's so
beautiful
she has so many followers yes she has
nine million followers on Tick Tock but
like people don't know who she is do you
know she has nine million followers on
Instagram
she's not yeah that's crazy
but she has come she has legs what do
you think about that oh
okay I'm so glad you brought that up my
thoughts my question was that she has
her likes turned off so you just see
blank and others like the photo
so I would say nine times out of ten
when I see your likes off you're hiding
poor engagement I don't care what you
have to say like you are hiding the fact
that you either have like some sort of
fake followers or just like a really not
engaged audience and you don't you have
like fans and other people Dale
followers that you acquired years ago
that just like are not active accounts
anymore you didn't buy them no but like
they're not engaged with you
and I will say one out of those ten I do
believe is like really doing it for
their mental health yes
um with like just not interested not
wanting to put so much validation on
numbers and like emphasis on I don't
think that's but I think everybody turns
them off and says oh I'm doing this for
my health but I know you're doing it
because there's a element of fraudulence
to your business
yeah but I have a question if you and
wait sorry just know if you ever see me
turning that off it is because I am
getting poor engagement okay good to
know I have thought of instances where I
would turn it off and it wouldn't be
because of Engagement but it would be
because like I'm posting something that
I feel like strongly about and I don't
care how it does okay and but you have a
question most people turn off engagement
for their whole profile right it's not
just like one to take content but like I
feel like like I feel like Haley Bieber
like sometimes like turns off comments
on like a specific photo because she's
like I don't care what you guys want to
say about this by the way comments is
different to me yeah if you want to turn
off comments I understand it's like I am
not gonna on my page give a platform for
people to give me their thoughts on my
appearance that I understand
just but I'm talking about just likes
okay but I have a number of likes can I
ask my question
oh my God calm the [__] down [__] it's
Valentine's Day
[__] Christ I've had a question the
whole time okay I mean and I told you
this before we started recording you're
giving me a lag today so like I can hear
you three seconds after so I'm
responding late sounds okay sounds like
you have to come back here
why don't you get your ass up here [__]
I just spent 10 days at your
[__] house yell at me again I
[__] dare you
I actually ask you what was your
question I am coming up my question
wench was the person whose page it is
even if they turn off likes can they
still see how many people liked it
I don't know I've never done it yeah
because then it's like you can't make
the arguments really for your mental
health you still see but maybe the
mental health comes in because it's like
you don't have the pressure of like
showing other people how uh yeah
sickening you are
yeah no and then like other people will
look and be like wow comparing you know
I think it's more so for other people
not to see it I don't know if you see it
on your own end but I'm really glad you
brought that up because whenever I see
like certain people I'm like oh man you
are such a fraud like I know you're just
like having low engagement like own it
girl actually no I can't lie I respect
it because if that was me like I would
not own it and I would be like guys I
need to protect my mental health yeah
yeah because if I just saw whatever
number of likes she actually gets we
would have sat here and been like oh
he's finished but instead I'm like she's
protecting her peace yeah and like I'm
over here like speaking on my high horse
because like my Instagram like happens
to have like very high engagement but
like that could change in a year I just
know like I'm I'm not above hiding like
I will hide yeah when the day comes it's
there for me I will it's there for it
it will yeah take advantage of all the
tools that Instagram has to offer
hundred percent I think we all take
advantage of Instagram's tools
I think we all do too no I definitely
don't I do the same thing like I just
use stories and posts
no same you know they always have like a
new gimmick that they're Hawking
so true and it takes me like three years
too but if you're an early adapter
they'll push that [__] to everyone
so true but then everyone will hate you
because they're seeing your stuff it's
like getting that U2 album it's so hard
to be a creator
people don't know because like we make
it look so easy but this life it's so
hard like it's literally so challenging
and people don't know they don't know no
they don't but we're going to let them
know turdy because let them know turdy
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know this Valentine's
Day
and this gorgeous romantic loving
episode is brought to you by Caraway new
year new kitchenware with Caraway start
your year off right with non-toxic
kitchenware so you can ditch the
chemicals and make healthier cooking a
piece of cake if you have watched any of
our cooking Vlogs or watched our
Instagram stories like Jackie because
she cooks more but both of us like we
are obsessed with Caraway home if you
are best Beyond if you're like cooking a
romantic meal tonight for Valentine's
Day do the Caraway use their products
because your cleanup will be so much
easier and it's like on mess if you're
cooking that means like your man should
be cleaning up and if you're using
Caraway like he won't he physically
couldn't be leaving look it up chunks in
the bottom of the pan and like bird
marks and scrapes so it's good for
everyone it's good for your relationship
that the next time you go to use your
Caraway it will be clean
their internet famous cookware set is a
staple for any home and it comes in
multiple colors to fit with any design
aesthetic with our exclusive discount
you can save on the full Suite of
Caraway products that includes the food
storage the tea kettle the mini cookware
by the way I didn't have the food
storage and then I went to Jackie's
house and in her pantry she has the food
storage those little bin things genius
genius because it's so hard to keep like
you know your your cookware organized
but not with Caraway all their sets come
equipped with easy access storage
solutions so no stacking is required
gone are the days of misplacing your
lids and God are the days of toxic could
equip cookware all their products are
made without any toxic materials
visit carawayhome.com toast10 to take
advantage of this limited time offer for
10 off your next purchase the deal is
exclusive for our listeners visit
carawayhome.com
toast10 that's t-o-a-s-t-10 or use code
toast 10 at checkout Caraway non-toxic
cookware made Modern today's episode is
also brought to you by our favorite bar
the perfect bar looking for nutritious
and delicious snack we'll look no
further than perfect bar with their
lineup of fresh from the fridge protein
bars perfect bar is exactly what you and
your family need your New Year's
resolution to eat healthier should be
enjoyable right so why not stack on
something that's nutritious and
delicious this year perfect bar has you
covered with their lineup of fresh from
the fridge protein bars
they're made with freshly ground nut
butter organic honey and 20 organic
superfoods perfect bar has a variety of
products like protein bars and little
snack size bars too they are all so good
and good for you whatever your palette
you will find something you like you
know me pickiest eater alive the dark
chocolate peanut butter with a little
sea salt that perfect bar is so good I
love that you keep perfect bars in the
fridge it kind of makes all other bars
look really disgusting like claiming to
be fresh but it's a good one to be kept
in the fridge so question mark
how could you do this today question
mark
um oh and that's about our conversation
yesterday about keeping chocolate in the
fridge you know the perfect bar is a
good example of why you keep it in the
fridge it's the perfect consistency
literally
is fresh
right they're non-GMO project verified
they're gluten-free soy free low GI and
co-share it because perfect bar respects
the semites
um perfect bar knows that it'll be Love
At First Bite so for a limited time
they're offering you a chance to try
their refrigerated protein bars for free
here's how it works sign up for your
email or texts from perfect bar and then
upload a picture of your receipt from
your local grocery store and they will
reimburse you for the cost of one bar
it'll go directly into your venmo or
your PayPal account which is pretty cool
all you have to do is go to perfect
snacks.com toast to get a free perfect
bar today that's perfect snacks.com
toast to get a free perfect bar today
happy snacking you know what's better
than a snack a free snack 100 percent
100 that's my tip of the day our first
story Olivia Wilde finds herself in some
cringy Waters again
newly single to be a wild is calling
ASAP Rocky hot tagging Rihanna in a
cringy post Olivia Wilde called ASAP
Rocky hot on her Instagram story Monday
and tagged the rapper's pregnant
girlfriend Rihanna before deleting the
post mirror hours later so she posted a
reel to her story of ASAP Rocky like
like supporting and loving Rihanna's
performance at the Super Bowl and she
said if I thought he was hot before this
really put me over the edge
many fans found her caption to be cringy
and questioned why she would brazenly
tag the couple who have been dating
since 2012. people said it's
inappropriate Etc she removed the post
from her story I'm in the backlash
before addressing her followers who got
it twisted saying it's hard to respect
your partner especially when your
partner just did that
okay let me say how I actually
conceptually really agree with her point
the point being like men you know who
support like really kind of I would say
more successful women than them and like
are so supportive and not intimidated
like I agree that's an extremely
attractive quality but Olivia Wilde like
out here being on the same level of Fame
as them and like tagging them like and
her verbiage it makes it cringe 101
however I do support the message I want
to say I agree and if she were a lay
person and I just saw a friend of mine
horses on their feet I'd be like oh you
can think you know ASAP Rocky's Hot we
all have a celebrity crush and now he's
even hotter because he supports his
woman
um I wouldn't think twice about it but
the fact that she's a fellow celebrity
who's like they're going to hear about
this and even if she had just said what
she said in the second part like it's
you know it's hard to support your
partner but she said if I thought he was
hot before which
so you're crushing on him so you're
crushing on him which is fine when
you're a late person but it's like weird
when you're a fellow celebrity
I can't explain what the difference is
but it's weird
um so random but I saw this on Twitter
this morning and I like rolled my eyes
hard and I was curious did you make it a
story about Bethany no
okay she's like really annoying me but
like she like has to you know she has to
comment on everything and she's like
getting backlash for her comments on the
Rihanna
um Super Bowl performance she said it
was good but not great
I saw her perform years ago during the
same month that pink performed she was
much less inspired than Pink as a
performer she wasn't even comparable
pink was just like so incredibly
passionate I thought I would just throw
it up throw it up because Rihanna puts
business first the Super Bowl
performance was good and not great and
being pregnant cannot make that easy but
it was a spectacular Fenty brand
performance and that's where the big
Super Bowl win was last night take all
the money she has made Mickey music and
multiply multiply that by a lot for what
Fenty is making the rest is just to be a
vehicle for what that Mega Beauty brand
success she is one of the last few who
will cash out that way as a celebrity
Beauty brand are super saturated she
crushed that Fenty Beauty performance
and even she did a touch-up of her face
and a token touch and sniff on her
vagina which many of us could have done
without
um I like I'm in like my anti-betany era
which is so crazy because like you could
not catch me not defending everything
she did especially like that season of
um housewives in Colombia
I just like shut up
yeah no I don't care that pink was
inspiring a few years ago and more
inspired than Rihanna like I love pink
I'm constantly inspired by the game I
didn't watch Rihanna though and say pink
is more inspiring no it's literally that
Tick Tock sound why the [__] did you
have to bring that up like no one was
talking about pink literally and like
Bethany I hate to say this next three
words
as a woman yeah I know I know I hate
Jackson like Jackie Jackie yes yes to
what I hate to say these next three
words because like ugh but it's true as
a woman no and not not the mother no yes
as a woman who knows what it's like to
be pregnant not because women have to
blindly support other women no no
because she's pregnant it's like [__]
you know
you know what that must have been like
not even just getting up there and
shaking your thing but the months and
months of prep work when you feel like
hot garbage yeah so I said it yesterday
I will not tolerate any sort of Slender
about the performance and Bethany's just
like in this era of her career whether
it's on Tick Tock her podcast she has to
say like annoying outrageous things
that's how she gets pressed and it's how
like she feeds to her followers and gets
more followers and gets more listens and
I think that's the most annoying type of
celebrity and I feel like I never ever
expected that to become Bethany's career
post Housewives like she was too good
for all this stuff and now she's just
like you know in the sewer like everyone
else yeah the like and I hate to sound
like a teacher but it's like you can
have you know some less than Stellar
things to say about Rihanna's
performance if you if you no lesson
seller things to think about Rihanna's
performance if you can think whatever
you want but like why do you have to say
everything that you think like
it's just it's so unnecessary like
oh it was good not great okay so you
thought it was good no by the way I only
agree with that pertaining to this like
sure share your thoughts always but like
leave the pregnant woman alone
no share your thoughts always but like
it's so minute she's not even saying
anything like radical somebody new she's
just saying it was good not great pink
would have been better like does that
need to be said
no and it's like why don't you do your
research pink has refused the Super Bowl
halftime show she has
yeah why
she refused in 2019 when like the NFL
was getting like a lot of flack and
there was like a lot of controversy like
with the anthem she like stood with the
players and didn't want to work with the
NFL but the players work with the NFL
no that's a good point and I think also
um cardi B that was the year that Maroon
5 did it I think because like nobody
else wanted to do it yeah I don't know
if that two years where it was like
um
now that we've had a halftime show that
was remarkable this year I'm looking
back at the last few years I'm like yeah
those I can say now those were bad like
I didn't like last year's now seeing
remarkable oh I liked last year like
especially like if you're a huge fan of
hip-hop like if they had done that for a
country like you would have gagged and
people would have been like this sucks
that's true but it was just like so I
only remember it because like I was
watching and like in the hospital so
it's just like a memorable thing but
meh
so I actually was looking up yesterday
you know what the the most watched ones
are live
yeah okay
okay I can't remember who the third oh
the third was Lady Gaga okay
this who's the second I think the second
was Rihanna
but the first really surprised me
um yes
I'm so I'm gonna have to like uh Bruno
Mars
Coldplay
Katy Perry you're lying
I mean you have to think about what
where Katy Perry was at the time in her
career
hmm I mean I love her so important I
love her you know it's so important
it's so important for me to mention like
it was a tick tock so it might not be
like it started like I weirdly like do
not believe that and also this the
halftime show like I believe that
Rihanna brought viewers to the Super
Bowl a hundred percent but I think
generally speaking the halftime show is
like just watched by the people who are
watching no by the way it was right
Rihanna's halftime show averaged
118.7 million viewers making it the
second most watched in Super Bowl
history Katy Perry's 2015 performance
still holds the top Mark at 121 million
that's crazy but like and I mean I loved
her halftime show that's just surprising
I also wonder if 2015 was just like if
the NFL was more popular in 2015.
yeah you know I think there's a lot of
factors there's a lot of factors but
that's interesting um and then who was
it before last year
you want me to pull up let me pull up
the list yeah
it's because there was like a couple
years where like they had to keep
tapping Beyonce and Bruno Mars like
nobody else wants to do it um JLo and
Shakira I thought that was amazing I
thought it was great too
and then there was Super Bowl halftime
shows Maroon 5
businessman
and
Maroon 5 was and Justin Timberlake was
um
major that was the one that we were at
yeah but you know what we never saw it
on TV so we don't even know what it was
like
okay so Rihanna was this year last year
was the hip-hop um medley Eminem Dr Dre
Snoop Dogg oh the year before that was
the weekend I thought that was very
forgettable agreed
yeah Shakira and JLo I thought that was
great
Maroon 5 meh Justin Timberlake meh Lady
Gaga best of the best like Stellar she
put her a whole God Gussy into that
then before that was Coldplay Beyonce
Bruno Mars that was good really good
loved then Katy Perry
then Bruno Mars who brought out Red Hot
Chili that's one of my favorites of all
time
and then before that was Beyonce's solo
amazing leotard amazing 2012 Madonna
don't remember it
2011 the Black Eyed Peas uh really truly
I just saw a clip of it I remember it
being very bad
uh you know they were singing live
that's what I'll say okay
then 2010 the who I must have missed
that that's not for us
2009 Bruce I'm sure people love that I
feel like football fans and Bruce fans
there's a lot of crossover yeah so maybe
the views weren't that high because not
new people tuned in
right but also like times change 2008
Tom Petty
2007 and I believe this is probably
considered one of the greatest of all
time Prince and the Florida a m marching
band I think that's like the one people
are always referencing I don't think
I've ever seen it yeah 2006 Rolling
Stone then Paul McCartney 2004 of course
Janet Jackson how could we forget oh
2003 this is an iconic lineup Shania
Twain no doubt and sting
2002 U2 2001 Aerosmith in sync Britney
Spears Mary J Blige and Nelly so it was
like a medley
and then we're getting into the 1900s
and I'm just I'm not gonna that's where
our research ends very interesting so
anyways I think that this was the best
one in years
since Lady Gaga I agree
and that's what happens when you choose
one person
and that's why I like when you choose
one person yes I am personally not into
the medleys no I'm not into the Middle
East everyone becomes kind of
forgettable
sorry no and it's just like a you're
right it's just uh almost like a mosaic
and there's no you know what there is
another word yikes there's no
accountability if it's good who made it
good if it's bad who made it bad
right and what do you call it because
you won't say oh that was the year that
eight people performed and listen out
it's like oh that was Beyonce's year
yeah
I think the one if anyone from Apple
music they're in charge now one make a
choice well their first one their first
one was excellent so I have hope yeah
their first one was excellent
but you know what's so funny like when
it was the Pepsi show I don't think
Pepsi really got involved in terms of
like creative dancing lighting
choreography but I'm sure Apple music
gets involved now like for more of a
creative standpoint that's like what
they do
yeah I think they could just probably be
more helpful
yeah
but Pepsi has agencies and stuff for
everything I'm sure um
so anyways back to Olivia Wilde I also
want to take this time to mention that
Ted lasso season premiere date dropped
March 15th on Apple Plus
how long will it have been from season
two to season three
um
I do not know Googling
yeah yeah I just want to say so you said
when is it being released March 15th
of this year
yeah like next month in a month okay and
season two premiered of July 2021 two
years damn
that's crazy it wasn't even that hard
for us because we watched late
yeah of course like I of course always
late to everything yeah so I'm excited
about that just wanted to get everyone
excited my two episodes are dropping
weekly so I guess we'll be talking about
it in April
I cannot stand these streaming services
who literally changed our habits like oh
we're gonna be new and different we're
gonna bulk drop a season and we're like
oh we love this we got used to it and
now they're like even Netflix like oh
you like Love is Blind here's three
episodes [__] give me eight no they
turned us into addicts yes and now
they're taking away the problem but you
know what it is now I think I don't
think they can really keep up with how
fast people consume all their [__] they
spend like a year and 100 million
dollars making one season that people
will consume in two days talk about for
three and then move on from that's like
not a sustainable business but they got
us hooked on Netflix with this binging
which is was not yeah which was not a
healthy practice to begin with to spend
your whole weekend at home watching a
whole season of Television but that's
like now how the world works and now
they're taking it away from us no I
think they created a culture and a trend
in which they cannot keep up yeah
the the shelf life of a show that like
drops the whole season and goes viral I
mean Bridgerton literally their biggest
show we talked about it for a week yeah
in general I'm here for like healthier
television watching habits but
they don't get me hooked on things
hooked on stuff
yeah and then take it away yeah and now
liquid us we're monsters
literally
feening for Content our next story is
actually some more Super Bowl news drama
okay because Terry Bradshaw is facing
backlash for him I know wait wait can I
guess what it was because me and Ben
turn to each other
is it waddle yeah amongst a couple other
things for his Super Bowl post-game
remarks to Kansas City he should coach
Andy Reid so after the Chiefs won the
Super Bowl
Terry Bradshaw who's an analyst for Fox
NFL Sunday
show star oh right Bradshaw bunch he was
uh trying to get Andy Reid's attention
he said big guy let me get the big guy
in here come on waddle over here have a
cheeseburger on us
okay so I will say the cheeseburger
thing didn't shock me as much because
Ben said like this guy after every win
like has a burger that's like his thing
okay so it's so important to know that
the context but me and Ben looked at
each other when he said waddle because
that's a really [__] mean thing to
say to like an overweight older person
um and it's like all right Terry
Bradshaw calm down like you waddle too
okay right and I'm sure they know each
other and I'm sure it's fine and I don't
think Andy Reid gives a [__] but like I
as a viewer I was definitely like damn
Savage yeah I have to imagine that they
go way back Terry Bradshaw is not the
most fit so it's like right
you know it's kind of funny
no if like a young really fit person
would have said it fire on the spot
fired
fired but like I think that they have
this relationship it's reminding me of
like the Luke Bryan uh intro Dustin
Lynch like he's roasting him we don't
get it because like we don't know them
but like that's how they talk to each
other I think also like football talk is
just like [__] harsh different and
it's weird for a layperson to see it and
we're like so precious we're like PC you
can't talk like that it's Terry Bradshaw
being fat phobic no it's so true and
they're like shut up
I have to imagine it was some sort of
you know
unspoken bond between them yes I real
because Terry Bradshaw like is a
professional he's been in the business
forever I'm sure he knows this man
forever and some Congress some
conversations between friends doesn't
make sense to The Outsider
yeah it's also Terry Bradshaw's job to
know that millions of Outsiders are
watching your conversation
I just I'm gonna assume that that's the
case because the alternative is so
[__] mean and sad cruel
like Andy Reid was so cute so proud he's
like I'm not retiring like I love this
man and I refuse to let anyone
disrespect him so I'm gonna just live
under the guys that they're besties and
they joke about waddling all the time
yeah the alternative is cruel and I
actually learned some interesting fact
about Andy Reid and like his ties to the
Kelsey family is that Andy Reid used to
be the coach for the Eagles and when he
was the coach for the Eagles he drafted
Jason Kelsey and then he became the
coach for the Chiefs where he drafted
Travis Kelsey
wow so I'm sure Mama Kelsey has a warm
spot in her heart for Andy as well
yeah and so I don't think Mama Kelsey
would tolerate any sort of Andy Reid
slander no and he reads slander
disgusting oh Madam so what other people
picked up on that because me and Ben
were like tackling we're like what the
[__] that's so goddamn rude yeah that's
so funny also in the post game like when
they got on the field I think who did
they get to talk to First it might have
been Andy Reid but they were also trying
to follow the reunion between Travis and
Jason but they had Auntie read on and
like so the camera had to go to him
obviously it's a big get but like I was
like wait go back they're about to sync
up
like no when the game is over and
everyone's families come and the players
shake each other's hands like it's so
chaotic and honestly they pretty much
always do a good job of like getting the
moment no matter what the moment is but
it's tough that's a tough part of the
job I have to imagine like being the
camera coordinator like Josh dumel from
Life as we know it yeah but also to be
like the person on the field the feel
the sideline reporter but I think that's
also what makes you know the job that's
the exciting part of the job
you know when the game was over they had
all the players on the field before any
of the interviews started and I saw they
like were at a glance I saw Erin Andrews
[__] elbow her way through this mob
to get to
um Travis Kelsey and Patrick Mahomes
with her cameraman and you know what I
feel like that's a huge part of sideline
reporting that most people don't think
about it's like being an animal yeah you
gotta have sharp elbows I was like I'm a
go [__] she was literally plowing
through people like yeah it was crazy
love that for her could never be me yeah
uh my God actually it could no I would
be talking I just need a cocktail I'd
have the exclusive with the water boy
I'd say you literally would who drank
the most water
who drinks what kind of water was it who
drank the least water
and tell me like a little bit about what
one of the tougher parts of your job
and Juliana do you drink a lot of water
great question is there anyone who's not
allowed to have some of this water
okay like you're beating it to death no
I think there's a lot you could glean
from the water boy
well there's also I saw on the TV a
water girl like when people got off like
the offense or defense there was like a
girly with a Gatorade water bottle like
pouring the water in their mouths love I
saw that too I thought that was genius
they didn't have to take their helmets
off
okay because I saw someone doing it with
their helmet off and I was like oh wow
they can't even drink their own water
these tacos
it might have been because it was like
the group's water bottle so he couldn't
put his mouth on it
okay good point because honestly I was
judging might have been like coveted
protocol
um yeah yeah yeah good point
okay are you ready for our next story
which I'm finding fascinating it's one
of our favorite subjects to talk about
which is about no okay so I'd say like
top 20 favorite subjects okay which is
about having sex on screen with your
co-stars
intimacy okay
um in the Arts not in pornography
pornography yeah and we're always
talking about pornography so you had to
make that that was confusing
uh Penn Badgley is going deeper on
swearing off racy you sex scenes he said
that aspect of Hollywood has been very
disturbing so Penn Badgley has been in
the headlines recently and not only
because part one of the fourth season of
you dropped on February 9th on his
podcast pod crushed last week he talked
about his strong dislike of filming
intimate scenes and the internet
exploded with thoughts about his remarks
he also said that he shared his feelings
with Sarah gamble the you show runner
ahead of the season in turn he said
gamble had a really positive response
and they came back with a phenomenal
reduction for season four of all the
racy sex scenes
in two wide-ranging interviews for this
week's variety cover story which will be
released on February 15th Badgley spoke
expansively on the subject in our story
Badgley details how the number of sex
scenes he knew he'd have to do for you
had been a major factor in 2017 and him
not wanting to play the role of Joe
Goldberg who's a killer serial killer
and love addict I've never seen the show
the whole series after all were oh you
haven't
no and now it's Joko Burger Jew of
course they make the serial killer Regio
kill me totally the whole series
revolves around Joe's romantic stations
and how he gets the women he's fallen
forced to submit to his charms by Design
you has a lot of sex he spoke carefully
about describing his discomfort with sex
scenes quote having done a fair amount
of them in his career he said it's not a
place where I Blurred Lines there's
almost nothing I could say with more
consecration that aspect of Hollywood
has always been very disturbing to me
and that aspect of that job that
Mercurial boundary has always been
something that I actually don't want to
play with at all he's also now older
than his romantic interests on the show
and it didn't used to be the case he
said he wishes he didn't have to do any
sex scenes it's important to me in my
real life to not have them he said my
fidelity and my relationship it's
important to me and actually it was one
of the reasons that I initially wanted
to turn down the role I didn't tell
anybody that but that is why he's been
married since 2017 to Domino Kirk
yeah uh
I believe he's married to
Jemima Kirk's sister
no way Domino Kirk
okay that's so interesting
um I have to say I never thought I'd
hear like a man in Hollywood say like
he's uncomfortable that he has to kiss
women on screen who are younger than him
like that is next level like that's what
a normal person would say but people in
Hollywood don't seem to care yeah but he
said that his wife encouraged him to
take the role still
um and he was obviously going to listen
to her more than anyone and so in this
current season of you there are fewer
sex scenes and they are all performed
fully clothed
hmm I have mad respect for this
me too like to turn down a hit show for
see like Season Two Season one blew up
and to not want to return because of
like something you morally struggle with
um and then to make a change like to
actually enact change with the show
runner I think that's that's pretty cool
and to like admit that it's [__]
weird
which we all think and everybody you
know all the greats tell us that it's
not and it's just like you know playing
a part part of the job and it's not
romance we can't wrap our tiny little
lay people heads around how that could
be
so true because our brains are so small
no whenever anyone in a relation in a
film or TV show is asked about
intimacines intimacy scenes they're just
always like oh you don't understand like
it's such not a big deal but like to its
core you know being in a relationship
and whether it's real or fake putting
your lips on someone else like has to be
even slightly discomfort but it's not
even just kissing like and the way that
these scenes have increased yeah sexual
nature especially with the streaming
shows they're not on cable like they
don't have as many things and sensors to
worry about like things are getting
[__] crazy out there so true so maybe
back in the day it's like okay I can
kiss someone and not fall for them or
not have a feeling
um and but I think these days like the
sexual scenes are so much more graphic
that they're doing things completely to
be completely 100 naked
against another person even though they
probably have like socks on the genitals
like your whole body's skin to skin like
there's something deeply intimate about
that yeah so to just brush it off like
it's nothing is like it's a lie yeah but
also like it seems like in this show in
particular like it's extremely sexual
multiple partners a lot of sex and I've
never been with multiple partners not
every sex you know so in some movies
like you're gonna have this one partner
maybe the two of you are able to
compartmentalize you have like a good
relationship with that I'm just talking
like the actors you know yeah but to do
this like over and over and over again
like that is it's crazy and I'm glad
he's admitting it and he's trying to you
know stay faithful to his wife but his
wife is understanding but it's a crazy
part of the job especially as these
scenes get more and more gratuitous
yeah no we've definitely gotten to a
place where they're like insane like
I've like I there's just some crazy [__]
I've seen over the years on you're right
like streaming where there's no sort of
like you know Mothers Against
Parenthood you know that's why like so
much stuff can't be on cable it's like
those organizations for like kids
parents who don't want their kids to be
scrolling through and like see a boob
um but there is none of that it's
totally unregulated on streaming
services yeah because like you sign up
for it like you're consenting adult and
they can put whatever they want on there
yeah so I thought that was interesting
and he's never been like one of my faves
um as an actor but I'm just like oh
that's pretty cool no I have respect for
this I have respect
before we dive in to the next couple of
stories let me just tell everyone that
today's episode is sponsored by Third
love most bras suck and it's a real
bummer but third love knows that it's
not you it's the bra they have spent
years designing bras for your body they
make over 60 sizes and they even
invented half cups so you will always
get the perfect fit which means that you
will always look and feel your best
so whatever type of bra you're looking
for whether it's like an everyday bra
something more full coverage something
without a lining want a little bit of
extra lift a little Boom for Valentine's
Day third lab's best-selling bras are
all designed to fit and support your
body they have a style for every
solution and outfit and they will make
you look and feel great no matter what
you're wearing
um so I think the beauty of third love
and the reason why I fell in the I fell
in love with the brand like many years
ago is because I did not know what
actual size bra I needed until I took
their quiz and what's so crazy is that I
had gotten my boobs measured in like
stores before and even in store I got a
less accurate sizing than I did on the
third love website I could not believe I
was like literally wearing the wrong
size they asked so many questions in the
quiz like about your breast shape how
they hang your current bra size what's
wrong with your current bra size what
you like what you don't like it's really
helpful
and it's always important to keep doing
it because your bra size can change over
six times within your lifetime so they
make it easy to find your perfect bra
with their virtual fitting room it has
helped over 20 million women find their
perfect bra size and they have the
perfect fit promise you'll never get
stuck with a bad bra again returns and
exchanges oh I'm wearing my third love
yeah I'm wearing my third love bra today
ditch bad bras get a better one that
makes you look and feel great upgrade
your bra and get 20 off your first order
at thirdlove.com toast that's 20 off
your first order today at thirdlove.com
toast honestly it is time for you to
stop wearing like that broke down bra
get a new one
thank you turdy
yeah you're welcome
our next story Forbes has released the
world's highest paid 10 highest paid
entertainers
they were listed excuse me
they've released what'd you say released
use it you said we're list I don't know
what that means
immediately that's why I'm asking for
clarification because you said it
released
warp says release their list
these are my favorite lists yeah this
one's particularly interesting because
it's entertainers so it covers the gamut
it's how much they made this year
so keep those things in mind number also
I think lists like this it's so
important so important to also keep in
mind
that in order to be eligible for this
list you have to willingly submit like
financial documents to prove that you
made this so there's entirely possible
that people who are not on this list
because they didn't want to send their
[__] tax return to Forbes and they
don't want people knowing how much money
they make so just keep that in mind but
um
this lists a lot of the
people on it are because they made deals
this year that was public information
like they sold the rights to their music
and like we all know how much they made
they didn't submit that like you know
sometimes when people do deals like we
know oh it's a 500 million dollar deal
Forbes said they made 500 million
dollars like it's really not that hard
number one Genesis
230 million dollars the Pioneers who is
that they're the pioneers of progressive
rock
what's progressive rock
and they tell us the list with a 300
million dollar music right sale to
Concord Music Group in September so they
sold all their music for 300. sorry is
Genesis a band they're the pioneers of
progressive rock and if you don't know
what that means I can't help you because
I don't know
okay like what the [__] is Genesis
they're an artist on Spotify their
number one song is invisible touch
shall I play it
oh they're an old school British band
okay so they sold their catalog okay I
needed some clarification I understand
now thank you no you don't need to play
it fans of Genesis also like Phil
Collins Peter Gabriel
Emerson Lake and Palmer yes
so how much do they sell their catalog
for 300 million
also Phil Collins
is part of Genesis
[Music]
shining through yeah I Love Phil Collins
I would see him in concert uh totally
and it's like a little confusing I guess
he's one-third of Genesis which is
they're the pioneers of progressive rock
and don't you forget it
um touring and recording music royalties
also rounded out their income so that
was a nice big deal for Genesis
happy for Lily Collins's Dad happy for
Lily Collins
it's been a great year for Lily Collins
yeah it's always a great year for Lily
Collins though you never know what
someone's going through no so true but
like to be born into such privilege and
have you know like the perfect life yeah
naturally gorgeous
yeah she's really natural she's been
beautiful since she popped on the scene
at like 15. yeah great roles good talent
mm-hmm you know don't forget Blind Side
oh how could I number two sting 210
million dollars the 17-time Grammy
winner and former police front man uh
pocketed 300 million before fees by
selling his entire musical output both
solo and with the police to Universal
Music Group in February so another one
who sold his catalog
right so if anyone's wondering like why
Taylor Swift was like so mad about
owning her music like this is why
because at a certain point in everyone's
career Justin Bieber just sold his it is
your biggest asset and that's how you
like cash out of the music industry yeah
but it also is interesting to know that
people do sell their music
yeah by the way I'm sure Taylor would
have sold it if she had owned it that's
why she wanted it so that eventually she
could sell it yeah but she didn't buy it
from them
when they made her an offer she she
tried
they said they offered
and she said yes you did offer to but to
sell me back each album every time I
made a new one for you so like she would
have to make eight more albums with them
to get all eight back or however many it
was she's like okay you give me lover
I'll give you Taylor Swift debut it was
like a one for one right no but that was
Scott but I thought that scooter offered
for her to buy it when she was like
upset that he owned the company the
company that like worked with scooter
like I think was called like Shamrock or
whatever they offered to sell it to
Taylor and Taylor was like well if I buy
it I'm making money for scooter like
Suitor gets paid out she's like I will
not pay any sort of
I will not make a deal in in a in a way
where Scooter gets any sort of benefit
yes and then the original issue was that
that she didn't own her music Scott
borschetta owned it because she signed a
contract when she was so young and it
was not a good contract
no not at all but she was just like
happy to get a gig yeah but like that's
where the issue stems from is like the
fact that she didn't own her music to
begin with
yeah and most small artists with like no
sort of like people not who have no
viral on Tick Tock like they have no
leverage people who just like earnestly
want to get into the music industry
that's what record labels do they like
take advantage of them because every now
and then somebody hits and also because
the record label provides a service and
they're not running a chair yeah but
yeah of course it's a little Sharky not
a little like you know it's Sharky it's
Sharky and they it's predatory of like
young innocent people yes but the record
label could be the difference between
them you know continuing to make songs
on Tick Tock and doing a world tour yes
third Tyler Perry 175 million dollars
the actor director Studio Mogul had
another lucrative year thanks to
simultaneous income streams from film
his BET TV shows and the sprawling
production Backlot he outright owns in
Atlanta
in his second year amongst forbes's top
10 highest paid entertainers he is the
List's sole billionaire with an
estimated one billion dollar Fortune
I'm obsessed with Tyler Perry I feel
like every time I learned something new
about his business like I didn't know he
owned this huge Backlot you did every
Studio no like I am more impressed and I
just love him yeah he's incredibly
impressive
yeah and it's also impressive that like
he's the first person we've discussed on
this list who didn't
um have like one big sale it's like he
made all this money top three from like
multi that's like such a diversified
portfolio like to get money in different
revenue streams and and with that he
will be on this list again next year and
the other ones probably won't be will
not right yeah sustainable
yeah number four Trey Parker and Matt
Stone they're the duo behind South Park
and they had another banner year thanks
to earnings from a legacy HBO max deal
and Book of Mormon I didn't realize that
they wrote Book of Mormon the majority
totally see it the majority comes from
their Paramount deal signed in 2021
which guaranteed the pair 935 million
dollars over six years another one who
probably did not give their tax returns
to Forbes to care about being on this
list but it's public information
wait 935 it was so crazy like who the
[__] watches South Park Claire I know
what everyone does but like I literally
don't know one person no and like they
are geniuses
no and they have like years and years
and years of iconic episodes that people
are obsessed with and I'm sure that's
what the deal was you know selling the
catalog so they can live live and then
continue to create content for them for
the next six years
selling South Park to Paramount that's
it right probably yeah like the catalog
yeah another so that's who knows oh
they'll be here again next year because
they definitely just did 935 divided by
six six and so they'll be on this list
for next six years unless other people
out right next James L Brooks and Matt
Groening 105 million dollars they are
the creators of The Simpsons the same
but different same thing yeah they um
sold all 30 Seasons to Disney plus from
FX in April 2019 and a streaming deal
made after Disney's previous acquisition
of fox uh so
that's great
that's good for them next number six
like and that was crazy because of the
last three number of people have been
like
back end people
these things
um but number six is Brad Pitt with a
hundred million dollars
wow the majority sale of his plan B
production company in December earned
the actor an estimated 113 million
dollars after fees the deal also had
Hollywood chattering it's definitely
become a brand says one lawyer adding
that plan B in addition to producing
Oscar winners Moonlight 12 Years a Slave
and The Departed likely owns back ends
and has a development slate that would
increase its value
oh so he had a big sale he had a big
sale and he earned an additional 30
million estimated so he didn't submit
stuff if it's estimated from roles in
bullet train Babylon and the lost city
but that's so interesting you know who I
feel like will be on that list um in the
next few years is Margot Robbie like all
the movies that she does now she does it
all her own production company and
they're all Oscar contenders and I think
hers will be will be big like that too
that's so interesting I didn't know he
had one of those and then there's real
money in it I thought sometimes they get
into directing you know
passion project yeah I just I love to
see behind the screen
but no it's he produces most of his
movies big money maker
that's so interesting now it makes sense
why everyone does it yeah well not
everyone but like a bunch of people
number seven Rolling Stones 98 million
they grossed 136 million dollars from
their tour and record royalties and they
pocketed over 8.5 million dollars per
night on their 15 City Tour across
Europe per night
yeah
it's crazy nice
number eight James Cameron I'm still
awaiting your call 95 million dollars uh
the smash success of Avatar sequel made
him the first director of three of the
highest grossing movies of all time
alongside Avatar and Titanic his second
outing to Pandora netted him at least 95
million dollars according to Industry
insiders in a deal that's said to be
back end heavy with bonuses for crossing
certain box hold thresholds so that's
the back end is how you make
make make money but also you know making
the biggest movies of all time is how
you make money right right of course but
like I'm sure James Cameron's like
director fee from the studio was like
not that much but he's like yeah but you
every time this movie makes a dollar I
get 10 cents yeah
interesting makes sense number nine
tailored Swift 92 million dollars
combined income streams from physical
record sales streaming on platforms like
Spotify digital downloads licensing and
sync make up her earnings it begs the
question what can she do crashing
Ticketmaster with insane demand for her
midnight tour in November suggest an
even bigger 2023 for her and she'll be
on the road for 52 nights across the U.S
with a potential nine-figure payout as
well as a result yeah I'll be curious uh
what her number is next year because
this is just a regular year for Taylor
of being a singer you know merch album
but a tour is really where you make
money as a as a musician and I would be
very curious I'm sure every time she
does a tour she becomes like you know
the top
uh
rate like the top the most generated
revenue from a female tour like she's up
there with Beyonce and Madonna and I'm
sure this next one will just take it to
the next level yeah so no one had a
really big tour this year in
contemporary music like The Rolling
Stones had a big tour
um but the only person who comes to mind
is Harry Styles
yeah and he's not on this list
but you want to know why even though
it's so crazy like Harry Styles did not
play any arenas
sorry any stadiums excuse me I know but
like the amount of Arenas he was doing
like
so you don't have to work every night
that's true but if you do 10 arenas
like the Forum and Madison Square Garden
that's I think 20 000 people where's
like a MetLife Stadium's like a hundred
crazy number 10 big tour this year Bad
Bunny 88 million dollars yeah the Puerto
Rican rapper best known for combining
reggaeton uh Charmed Millions around the
world as he flew on a palm tree on tour
he appeared alongside Brad Pitt in
bullet train and challenged machismo
with gender fluid style The Lion's Share
of his income came from two tours
performed in arenas and his the world's
hottest tour which was his first time
playing in the biggest possible stadiums
endorsements with the likes of Corona
Cheetos and Adidas were icing on the
cake
right so he got on the list as somebody
who played stadiums Arenas and two tours
yeah and movie and album and
endorsements right he's working hard
interesting
was that the fifth and final no
oh that was the fourth and fourth
I'm sorry no that was the fourth and
penultimate
because our fifth and final story some
exciting news for us 90s kids
as Club 7 is reuniting for 25th
anniversary tour the British pop outfit
will play 11 Arena dates in the UK and
Ireland so nothing for us here in the us
but we could still be excited slimy
Americans the original Seven members
will set out for 20th anniversary
Nostalgia trip later in the year as it
stands they will play 11 Arena dates
scheduled to kick off October 13th in
Liverpool they put out a statement
saying after eight years it feels
amazing to announce that we're reuniting
and Performing together again we're so
excited to bring the S Club party back
to our fans across the country to
celebrate 25 years of us Club 7.
okay wait like not to be dumb what other
songs does S Club have oh Claudia never
had a dream come
um true till the day till the day that I
found you and even though I pretend that
I moved on you'll always be my baby Club
don't stop never give up won't you head
high is your head high and reach to the
top don't you let's see what you can got
bring it all back to you okay and I'll
hit you with so many more years Reach
for the Stars Climb Every Mountain Top
and just Reach for the Stars ah there
you go okay all right good thing they're
not coming to America because now I want
to go literally I wouldn't probably go
to this if it were conveniently timed
for me and if it were happening in my
area code in your country in my my
country
wait that's so great I love a reunion
I'm glad that they're all still you know
all seven but so we don't have to like
feel all seven
I love that that's so great I'm excited
for the Irish they deserve it yeah and
the British ain't no party like an
escort gonna show you how yay I was
obsessed like that music video for S
Club party like watched on repeat they
were sickening
they really were they were so iconic I
wonder what they look like now they look
like seven 25 years later
they look like S Club 70. yeah except
like I think they've lived at very
normal lives and have you know embraced
the aging process and aren't like love
that wax figures
love that for them yeah well to our
British and Irish toasters get tickets
tickets if you're in Liverpool you're
not going to want to miss that
you are not going to want to miss it
and those are the past five stories
me and Margo were planning this year to
go to Luke combs in London I think he's
playing the O2
and are you okay and what about your
other sister I like you're always
welcome like we'll plan the trip and
like if you're I'm sure for sure but
like I know I'm welcome like I know now
that I know about it but like if you
didn't mention and you guys like planned
in and you just like booked it like the
more advanced notice I have the more of
a possibility okay by the way like me
but I mean Margot and I planning we're
like we sent it when he announced it we
like send it to each other on Instagram
we're like we should go okay when is it
I don't know but if there's like a
crossover S Club performance like even
like an hour away
yeah
s yeah Club ain't no party like a nice
club gonna show there's actually no
party like a toast party and that's what
we've had here today we did
we did thank you Jax for the gorgeous
Stories the gorgeous Diaries you're
welcome thank you toasters for tuning in
to the toast the millennial Morning Show
where we deliver the past five stories
that you need to know every Monday
through Friday on YouTube so if you're
watching this on YouTube [__] feel free
to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found so at
Spotify iTunes touch your public radio I
have ready to castbox to all the places
whoever you listen to podcasts find us
the toes leave five star review about a
beautiful stunning and wickedly talented
we are
hope you guys have a great day we'll see
you tomorrow for hump day can't wait
love you bye